what  game  did Neil Patrick Harris invent well I've  done a couple games boxed games one's  called Amazed quick word puzzles the  board that you're playing can fold and  unfold and refold in all sorts of  different ways so the board itself is  always different I've also after that  did a game called box one that's dope  it's a party game for one person box one  too many of these games require too many  people to play what if you're by  yourself it's not what you think it is  when you start playing it it's a bit  escape the roomy  something's in my eye  uh and I can't say more about it because  then it screws up the experience we're  working on box two right now what will  it be wouldn't you like to know it'll at  least be more expensive  probably won't actually  [Music]